si vous regardez ceci si vous avez reçu
un calendrier de l'avent respecter les
règles
[Musique]
serbie j'ai fait la joyeuse anniversaire
un calendrier de l'avent
respecte toutes les règles jusqu'à
l'ouverture de la dernière fenêtre a
sinon je te tue attention on avale un
faux les avaler tous jésus dit au
paralytique lève toi et marche devrait
arrêter avec ce calendrier safa 35
bah tu prends bien tes méthodes contre 2
hallucinations touche en marche
j'ai marché
[Musique]
tu devrais arrêter d'avaler toutes ces
saloperies
tout calendrier va juger tout secret
fait
trois personnes entourant mourir
cette nuit tu me fous la paix
[Musique]